thank you very much for talking to us
today you helped negotiate this deal you
gave years of your life to try and make
this deal happen
the Americans have walked away from it a
year ago and that looks like your own
government may withdraw at least
partially from it do you think the jcpoa
is a dead deal now not yet we are very
hopeful that we can in fact get some
decisions to rectify the situation but
the decisions that Iran has taken at
this moment is within the parameters of
the jcpoa it's not in fact this time to
undermine the jcpoa they are this time
to enforce the jcpoa in a manner that
jcpoa could be implemented effectively
because the jcpoa has not been
implemented for a while Iran has been
committed and implementing all its
obligations but the other sides have not
been able to implement their obligations
and that is a situation that cannot be
continued in this manner so Iran wanted
to give a very important signal that
things should be rectified and should be
redressed so we have used the jcpoa
parameters itself to give the signal
that we want other parts and parties to
also implementing their obligations by
jcpoa most people they understand the
Iranian nuclear deal you have said to
Europe they must do certain things
otherwise you will do certain things
there'll be consequences in two months
time what happens if the Europeans do
not react in a way you want them to as I
said there is a deficit of a confidence
further confidence between the parties
and we have not been able to receive the
in fact the advantages that are defined
within the jcpoa for our economy so we
have been implementing or commitments
without receiving the proper returns for
those obligations so we hope that the
European partners
would be able that after the one-year
patients from Iran to find negotiated
solutions which would allow that Iran
would be able to export its own and
receive the revenues but Europeans
surely would have done everything that
they can by now
what else can they do what more have
they got to give that is exactly point
that in fact they should be able to be a
little bit more vigorous and taking some
of the risks because these things are
not or not easy issues they should take
some risks to be able to salvage the
nuclear deal otherwise it cannot be
continued the way it is and if they
don't your government's prepared to go
back to enriching uranium we are for the
moment engaged in enriching uranium but
there are certain parameters and we are
bound to in fact to implement our
commitments including the enrichment
uranium within those parameters but we
have said that if these cannot be
sustained
we were suspending some of those
parameters and we would be beyond some
of those parameters defined in the
nuclear deal and people like Jeremy Hunt
the British Foreign Secretary he said
there will be grave consequences for
Iran if you do so does that not worry
you there would be certainly grave
consequences from Iran if they would not
be able to find a solution and we have
we have already elaborated that what are
those consequences and if in certain day
60 days would not be a solution Iran
would be implementing its second phase
measures that has has been announced and
certainly the situation would be worse
and we hope that in fact they would take
this message from Iran very seriously
and find a solution but is your
government in a position to be setting
out ultimatums to Europeans who say
they're doing what they can to try and
make this deal work it's not ultimatum
it's only call for effective
implementation of the deal there is a
deal that has been multilateral
achievement
and the success of the multilateral
diplomacy and what Iran is is is asking
is the implementation of the deal
looking at what America is doing they've
moved b-52 bombers to the region they've
moved an aircraft carrier Strike Group
they're talking about 120,000 soldiers
possibly going to the region you're a
seasoned diplomat do you think America
is looking for a fight looking for war
and if it is is Iran ready for that I
think part of this is within the
theatrical maneuvers by the by the US
administration our analysis is that the
day at least the present Trump doesn't
want to engage into a military
confrontation with Iran because he knows
that how much it would be costly for the
United States and for the region but
while we we have renounced any
escalation military escalation in the
region I would assure that Iranian
government and Iranian armed forces are
fully ready for any eventuality in the
region so they should not really try to
test the determination of Iran to
confront any in fact escalation in the
region it sounds like they're preparing
for the possibility of conflict they are
preparing as I said so some of this can
be can be seen as theatrical maneuvers
but we are also prepared for any
eventuality and for the first time I can
I can tell you that Iranian nation is
fully supporting the government to in
fact prepare for such eventualities to
prepare for different scenarios there
are reports that the Iranians were
behind these sabotage attacks on
freighters and tankers in the Gulf and
today reports of pipelines in Saudi
Arabia being attacked is Iran behind
those attacks unfortunately this is not
a new thing that any any problem in the
region is attributed to Iran or as they
call it proxies of Iran we have always
rejected these possibilities and Iran is
the first country is interested to keep
the peace and stability in the region
we in fact are very cognizant about the
sensitivity of the situation and we are
very concerned and very suspicious about
these acts done yesterday unfortunately
there were misinterpretations and even
for a part a good part of the day the
the countries engaged we're rejecting
[Music]
the possibilities for such sabotages but
suddenly we saw that there are here and
there gathering some news that would
channelize the news in a manner that
they would be trying to in fact be
trying to engage Iran with this we
totally reject this it is very
suspicious to us and we hope that the
international fact-finding mission could
really find the the reasons for these
sabotages which was very suspicious to
us G thing around is being framed and
blamed for this unfairly Iran has been
always unfairly blamed for many things
in the region we have been a country
which has been paying many costs for
keeping the peace and stability in the
region being in our relations with our
neighbors which have very good relations
with in the Persian Gulf so we would be
committing to our international
obligations and also also a
responsibility to keep peace and
stability in the region the Americans
say their policy is working and that
they are putting your government under
enormous pressure it's just a matter of
time before the government either Falls
or is forced back to the negotiating
table is that a fair characterization of
where your government is now do you
think maybe not the whole the whole
system in the US but unfortunately
unfortunately partially that has been
the in fact the the simp the
simplification of the kind of illusion
that they have that in fact they can
pressurize Iran and the government of
Iran and they can really look for regime
change in Iran but I tell you that
Iranian
nation is very solid at this moment even
some of the some of the elements and
some of the political parties in Iran
which were and it had been skeptical
about the approach which has adopted by
the government or now fully supporting
the government that we should merely be
resisting any provocations by the US
because Iran has been very faithful in
implementing its shares of obligations
and now this is a time that the other
parties should also behave very
responsibly in the region and the main
parties to the jcpoa nuclear deal to
also implement their obligations how to
ask you about this woman who was charged
and sentenced for spying yesterday in
the wake of Nazneen - Gary Ratliff as
well the government and NASA needs
husband says that the Iranians are
engaged in hostage diplomacy why is
around continuing to arrest these women
and charging them with espionage each
day thousands of Iranian dual nationals
including the UK Iranian dual nationals
are traveling to Iran through various
flights and never we have adopted a
policy of intimidation against world
national duel Nationals because they are
very respected Iranians which we
appreciate what they are doing in the in
the UK but certainly death should not
misunderstanding that if certain of
these 12 nationals would be engaged in
illegal activities certainly they should
be also expecting to be to be fixing
with with punishment by the law so this
is an incident that we also are pursuing
this to receive more information from
Tehran but as I said this should not be
seen as a policy that would be
pressurizing against the dual nationals
but Iran is in a very
of course sensitive situation and if
there would be a decision by some dual
nationals or some Iranian Nationals to
contravene the the law and be in fact be
in relationship illegally with the
secret services or intelligence services
to in fact adopt some some decisions
against their own country's they should
be expecting to face the law let me ask
you personally you've been very involved
in this nuclear deal
you've been ambassador here now you've
been very involved in improving
relations between the west and Iran how
worried are you how frustrated are you
by the way things are going under the
Trump administration and what we're
seeing now was a nuclear deal the
reality is that after the withdrawal of
the United States from the nuclear deal
the situation is not very helpful
because we were expecting that the level
of cooperation including the economic
field and trade area would be promoted
between the two countries
a lot of good contracts and agreements
were they were signed between the two
sides in fact which we're very
encouraging but unfortunately after
these incidents the UK companies have
been under tremendous pressure to cut
their relationship with Iran which in
fact proved that we cannot continue to
in fact to live under this pressure so
the European three or fully responsible
that in fact they would adopt some
measures that would protect the UK
companies that they would be in no more
relationship with Iran and that is
exactly what we are seeking and we hope
that in fact the relationship between
the two countries in terms of trade
economy and other areas would be
bringing prosperity and happiness for
the two nations and we hope that it can
be in fact the situation would be better
and better and we would be able through
a negotiated solution
find a solution to allow the UK
companies to enter into a good
relationship with with their Iranian
partners